وسط موجه حزن عارمه شيع في منطقه رحيبه
قرب العاصمه دمشق الفنان السوري الراحل
شادي زيدان عن عمر يناهز 49 عاما وكان
الراحل قد دخل الى المستشفى قبل عده ايام
بعد جلطه دماغيه ونزيف حاد بالدماغ ليبقى
في حاله حرجه لاسبوع تقريبا مع عصابته
بالغيبوبه قبل ان يداهمه الموت شيع
الفنانون السوريون النجم السوري الراحل في
اجواء من الحزن والدموع التي طغت على
لحظات الوداع الاخيره
خصوصا من اخوه الفنان السوري لسيما النجم
الكبير ايمن زيدان فبحسب مقربين من شادي
فان المشهد الاخير قبل اصابته بالنزيف
الدماغي كان لتشخيص وشخصيه تصاب بازمه
صحيه لكن التمثيل تحول لحقيقه في تلك
اللحظه ليكون المشهد الاخير حقيقيا في
حياه شادي زيدان الفنيه